hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to binding of issac now
I actually know how to play the game
properly amazing that in the last series
I got through all of this and had no
idea what the hell out damn it
again right off the bat take damage cuz
I'm a fool I'm a bloody fool against
these bloody eyeball people oh well
isn't that lovely thank you for that I'm
so happy but I don't know why that was
there okay ah lucky foot it's not a
rabbit's foot it's literally just a foot
so why do I have it why do I the butter
bean has appeared in the basement I
don't know what the butter bean is what
do you mean the butter bean has appeared
in the basement i just opened a pile of
poop i don't know what the butter bean
is did i get the butter bean before why
don't I ever remember anything when I
play games I literally remember nothing
I could probably at some point in my
youtube career I will play the exact
same game that I watch hot blooded me I
will play the exact same game that I've
already played and not realize it like
it would just be that way dammit I don't
have any bombs oh you're a big thank you
thank you for murdering yourself on the
fire that really is appreciated by me
alrighty then maybe this is gonna go
much better this is not gonna go well
for me yeah zombies yeah they're
horrible zombies with weird bodies okay
you know what I don't know how I'm gonna
be able to kill all these people how am
I gonna be able to kill them wait
no how do
what how are we gonna be able to all
this poop okay there's poop I I didn't
realize it was poop in every one of the
things okay okay I thought panicking for
a second there and I didn't need to okay
everything's fine
Oh God zombies I should start panicking
come at me bro come at me weirdo bro
what's up bro what's up bro what's up
bro huh you even left right
you even left with your weird eyes
breath huh breath you want to go with me
huh toe to toe bro hey too bad for you I
got a Golden Horseshoe I don't know what
that's gonna do for me well there's
nothing in here hmm but I do want that
because I believe that's a soul thingy
Oh
Mamadou boom boom badoom a lucky rock
has appeared in the basement oh good
again they don't know what they do for
me where do I need that hello you want
to go bro you all want to go Brad rare
bro bro bro bro I don't have any keys
bro I gotta go fight the boss bro
there's nothing I can do for that bro
nothing hello
woah rag man you don't look so fun you
look particularly scary and you looked a
lot bigger than you actually are so I'm
not particularly worried about you well
hey what what do you think you're doing
there hey what's going on why did you
turn into a spider how did you grow a
second head what is this crazy black
magic that's going on here there's some
weird stuff happening that I don't much
appreciate it
no geez oh geez oh gosh you have the
homing shots I used to have that but
then I took an arrow to the knee smoke
weed everyday' I don't appreciate this
at all you're a loser oh god you're not
a loser bro geez hey that's the cool
with the multiple spiders which one is
the actual you oh god they take they
have different damage than the other one
this guy is really hard doesn't seem
very fair but I'm gonna do my best cuz
I'm a badass
Oh driven into a corner now maybe not
maybe they just don't care what they're
doing okay there we go yeah I'm gonna
get your body I'm a focus on your body
if I could actually hit it that'd be
nice okay ow ow ow don't die don't die
not yet not yet not yet come on I can't
do the horrible for Honus that I had in
the last game he's hiding behind his
Spidey Bros they won't a vu now whoa
jeezum 'he's almost gotcha oh [ __ ] bro
oh oh gosh you're [ __ ] oh god damn it
whoa whoa whoa whoa come on sock just
you and me now you see me now the old
forgotten head he ripped you off and
then threw you aside you mean nothing to
him bro
wonder where mom's underwear why am i
wearing it why am i wearing my mother's
Underpants
I don't know how am I even playing me
afterbirth DLC that's what I want to
know is this really the afterbirth tub
oh oh oh no I think it is I'm pretty
sure it is it's got to be all right so
the new features that were added in
afterbirth which I probably shouldn't
looked at before I started playing this
game I just wanted played again this is
fun it's fun guys there's a new greed
mode with heavy focus on risk reward
featuring a new ending in a final boss
bloom daily runs new characters by the
name of Lilith and keeper 95 new items
29 new trick its new pickups chest fills
and cards 10 new challenges for new
alternate chapters earning basement
flooded caves dank depth and scarred
womb new special seeds expanded
soundtrack 9 new transformation new
bosses with new variations new monsters
new combo system combo not combo new
achievements new co-op
babies in an improved collection page so
let's see what I can find
after I die because I'll probably try an
agreed mode after this well hey weirdo
ooh what is this what what is this what
does this ooh
what is what is this what is that what
was that was the battery I don't know
what the battery is that like a combo
item is that what who's talking about
and I was talking about item combos
maybe I don't know hang on okay
I need oh another battery what is this
what are these what are they for
why are there batteries in these rooms I
don't know what are Black Keys oh those
are worth five that's right could've
sworn something in this one shot a blood
ball at me it did those do ah okay but I
got to find out what these batteries are
for because what's that writing on the
ground it's like a battery connected to
a guy on the ground I have no idea what
that means
it's got to be something to this ooh one
of these it's got to be something here
there's something that I'm not getting
about these batteries here what do they
mean uh Blair blurgh blurgh I'll be
right there
whoa not you we're here well that's it
oh oh oh oh oh no likey I know like yeah
I know like he I know like you know no
no no no no no no no no
hey cool I guess I did it oh god damn it
well this is not worth it at all this is
not worth it at all
Oh again god damn it Oh piss me Oh piss
me I'll piss Leland there we go okay I
need this I need this for the special
door not this one at the bottom there's
a golden door up above that if I get
that one I'll be able to know what and
why am i peeing my pants
why am i peeing my pants at the end of
every entrance of every dungeon I don't
know
oh good a turd but bombs toxic blast +5
bombs I don't want to put bomb
why is this a thing why is this the
curse of Isaac where is this the Binding
of Isaac you want a butt Bob
I have a butt bomb blubber ski huh I
didn't make it good
maybe there's a heart in one of these
turds that I can use just maybe just
maybe I'm gonna use this on the boss but
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
survive long oh well here we go hey
guess I still don't know what the
batteries are all about but let's go
come on little horn I don't know if I've
ever faced you before but I got but
bones oh god no you want a fight bomb -
bomb baby
oh are you toxa sized it's toxic to you
maybe I can fight you with your own
bombs I don't know I've never fought you
before so I have no idea if there's a
new boss or not I'm trying to wrap my
head around exactly what I'm doing here
gonna get you next time though well no
hahahaha now who's the master now I'm
out of bombs [ __ ] I can do this I can do
this do this I can do this do this do
this
yeah
that's just a permanent hole in the
ground isn't it ye not good not good not
good not good not good okay good pulling
away we're okay we're okay
oh god that's not good almost got you
almost got yours yes baby
some roids for my baby uh you know where
I said that but was there anything else
in here besides the batteries oops I
don't know what they're supposed to do
Oh God
whoa what did I actually do this doesn't
seem like roids okay I'm gonna go
anything no I don't know what I actually
got but apparently it's good I suppose
I jumped down into the hall and I don't
know I died I actually died that's what
happened Pookie alrighty then none of
this is good
none of this is good none of this is Oh
God ill I didn't know you were actually
a thing yeah you're just a hard most
skull see the thing is I haven't played
this game enough to know exactly what's
new and what's old so the entire
experience is just new for me that I
like it
it's ooh look of belial temporary damage
up and I use that with space
ah okay Herbert fruit birch oh I guess
it's only used for one room at a time
excuse me sirs can you not be douches
please oh god damn it
these guys are a-holes oh god these guys
are real a-holes
oh god nothing to die to stupid a-holes
stop it
oh no oh god damn it
well I guess we're going again someday
I'm gonna be able to beat this whole
thing but maybe not I'm in a burning
basement why am I in a burning basement
I need to play with a game controller
but I don't have one at the moment I'm
not in my normal setup it's new
I'm still getting used to everything
okay but I'm gonna be better I'm gonna
be better for you guys because I believe
in you
friendly fly oh goody goody goody
gumdrops
okay I'm gonna rush through this I'm
gonna go faster
so haven't been one to go fast exactly
why did that guy blow up I don't know
all right I'm gonna skip ahead until I
get to the boss because that's when
things get interesting so be right back
oh those buttholes
all right let's fight it okay back to
the boss who honked
I think I might a fight you before you
look kind of nope you do not look
familiar in the least I have no idea who
you are and why you're doing your things
okay so I got a kill its babies first
and then I attack the main thing is that
will how this do damn these whoa cheese
these babies just don't leave oh god
damn it
damn it okay I'll be right back
oh good least I'm getting new enemies
every time really bizarre but works for
me
damn I am cleaning this guy up I'm see
shots are so powerful oh my god it
racked him speed ball speed plus shot up
oh my god it wrecked him how I look so
happy oh nice nice nice man I can't lose
this I'm doing good
are they shooting are they shooting [ __ ]
out of their front butter they spun
around on that one okay I'm not going
through that door no way now I'm not
wasting it mm-hmm boo boo what the oh
god damn it with the head Jesus stop my
head exploded and boohoo oh hello oh I
like this I like it this this is nice
this is real nasty a lot of the
randomness comes down to well randomness
so it is nice when things go my way
every once in a while oh I don't have a
key oh no oh no maybe one of these rock
piles would have a key probably not by
very very low chance than anything here
would have a key ah man that sucks oh
well it is what it is
yep no key for me okay so carrying on to
the boss
bring it on whoever you may be Oh
monstro you're an easy one too bad I
died on you before but that was just a
fluke
it's a fluke a fluke whoa
it's hard to get a beat on them so my
superpower won't there we go
more powerful more powerful more
powerful power power power power power
power power power power blue you Beast
hey I'm the winner on the winner baby
and I got mom's underwear and there's
something over there maybe it'll give me
a key
oh hey Oh God bogey ish how's it go in
there buddy oh well I just lost those
yeah you got me a key now I can go up
over there
whoo perfect perfect the perfect the
perfect perfect perfect I can get
another powerup for my pontification to
pip appeal whoo oh oh damn that guy go
through the spikes [ __ ] how okay how to
jump
Wow whoa oh my god whoa oh damn
that's not bad actually hey wait huh Oh
what I can't jump over rocks I can okay
that's my convey why can't I jump over
this way I guess I need some momentum
okay I gotta learn how to do that go
down I'm doing good guys I'm doing good
aren't you proud of me I'm doing good
oh no I'm a peepee
all right okay so that's a good enough
place to end when I'm not doing horribly
horribly horribly so thank you everybody
so much for watching I'm probably gonna
play just one more episode to get to the
very end of this particular dungeon
because it seemed to be going very well
for me and I'm not gonna die I promise
you that I'm not gonna die if you check
in the next episode and I die you feel
free to write whatever you want in the
comments about me I will read it and I
will cry like a little baby and I will
do tears all over my face so thank you
everybody so much for watching and
remember that's only if I died don't do
that normally
you-you-you unleash your power on me I
will cry I will cry so thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye whose only when they were
in the apartment what am I missing
what am I missing
turns magic and purple tears